na wer ist für dich schuld an den 22
laschet söder merkels haben wir hier ein
genannt mich ist daran schuld dass die
cdu nicht sexy ist also ist ein bisschen
komisch an das jüngste was ihr cdu zu
bieten hat ist philipp am tor
findet man bei armin laschet sehr stark
merkt er kämpft ja auf eine viel
schwierigere umfeld als olaf scholz bei
armin laschet schwingt ja so ein
bisschen mit hör ich auch mal beim
bekannten freundeskreis warum soll ich
jemand wählen denen die meisten aus der
partei nicht mehr haben wollen wie soll
ich den denn meine stimme geben den die
halbe partei nicht leiden kann und das
hat olaf scholz gar nicht und deswegen
finde ich dass armin laschet eine viel
schwieriger position hat zudem olaf
scholz steht ja für vertrauen für
kontinuität als vizekanzler und
finanzminister hat ja schon mal so die
leute kennen ihn man kennt ihn ja die
auch die märkte jetzt nach gemacht auf
dem cover sieht deutschen magazins ich
finde dafür welchen posten amila schien
gerade hat hat er sich heute gut
geschlagen wer geht mit nina dakar an
wer stand dagegen mit stimme dagegen
habe ich habe schon gesagt wenn er nicht
möchte ich noch erwähnen was ist wenn er
den satz sagen
natürlich sehr sympathisch aber jetzt
mal zu mal trägt ein stück weiter
mitleid ist kein grund jemanden zu
wählen und niemand wird aus mitleid aber
ich fand das war schon mehr als mitleid
ist dass das armin laschet
absolut auch in dieser in der harte
dieser befragung zu einer absolut
leidenschaftlichen hochform auf
halloween ist da kann man immer noch
darüber diskutieren ob man jetzt all die
konkreten inhalte heraus gehört hat die
man gern raus hören würde da bin ich
auch er noch beim 1 aber ich finde dass
er durchaus gezeigt hat mit welchem
geist mann und das ist ja die
eigentliche botschaft des abends sich
von diesen verheerenden 22 prozent
vielleicht noch mal zurückkämpfen kann
denn dass die beiden großen
volksparteien die mal ungefähr was 80
zoologen dass ich jetzt so in ihre
richtung kuka habe solche angst in
diesem lande
der campus namen helmer mehr ohne hat
man alleine 48,8 und als sonst weil er
keinen partner hat als mathe versager
kann nicht trotzdem gerade noch
ausrechnen dass helmut kohl damit mehr
hatte als diese beiden parteien
volkspartei ist jetzt noch zusammen und
das ist ja eigentlich ein trend der eine
grundsätzliche von den wichtigsten
bewegungen in unserem land ganz
eindeutig verdeutlicht und das ist ja
etwas was alle beunruhigen sollte und
armin laschet hat eine zahl genannt
gesagt er glaubt dass 30 prozent als sie
gesehen und da kann man sich jetzt
ausschütten vor lachen wenn man die die
kurve ist sozusagen der letzten tage und
wochen sieht man kann aber auch sagen da
hat zum ersten mal einer den arsch in
der hose gehabt eine zahl aus zu auto
diese drei erreichen will diese drei
monate vorher eine blamage gewesen wenn
vorarbeit ist wenn er vor zwei jahren
hatten eine unionspolitiker sagen wir
wollen bei 30 prozent holen wären das
ist das ist halt so wenn du wenn du
irgendwo im sport antrittst und liegt
seit 20 zurück und sagt dann ich werde
glaube aber ich kann noch 3 2 gewinnen
dann ist das eine steigen auch wenn
vorher alle gedacht haben woraus die 40
weg also das ist vielleicht ist das
sogar das richtige
armin laschet scheint begriffen zu haben
dass also sozusagen wie die 78
spielminute ist in diesem wahlkampf also
da ist nicht mehr viel zeit und
verlängerung gibt es wahrscheinlich
nicht und er muss jetzt sozusagen
irgendwie schwung holen und ich nehme am
heutigen abend mittel stimmt er sich das
vornimmt und dass er es heute in teilen
auch eingelöst hat und geliefert hat
wohingegen olaf scholz offensichtlich
sozusagen mit mit dem mit dem wissen
dass man wenig handeln muss extrem
teflon ich sein muss weit kommen kann
und ich glaube das ist in der tat so ist
dass die den zug gewechselt haben
laschet sitz der zum express und scholz
dem schlafwagen da peter bonde deshalb
bin ich sehr gespannt auf die nächsten
wochen bis zum wahltag also dass auch
die team probleme zutage kommt also das
holz muss sein team verleugnen um weiter
erfolgreich zu sein und lasche brauchen
laschet muss endlich und das habe ich
heute übrigens vermisst er sprach ideen
aber er hat nicht erklären was habe ich
denn für ideen was in meine ideen meine
pläne für deutschland und er hat auch
nicht erklärt wer sein team ist den
süden moment nicht genutzt und hab
gesagt
der gehört zu machen aber das hätte
vielleicht keiner geglaubt wenn dann
gesagt hat ja aber das hab ich mir auch
wenn ich so sehr unter druck stehe
markus söder eine sehr große rolle
spielt sehr wichtig und ja sehr große
rolle spielen wird das war einmal noch
von jedem von euch ein akteur statement
hören wer ging an diesem abend ein
entscheidendes interview mit den beiden
kanzlerkandidaten die derzeit 22 prozent
22 prozent liegen wer ging hier als
gewinner hervor wie generell nach klaus
laschet zum ist keiner von beiden war
dass abwehrspieler keine presse für mich
ist ganz klar der verlierer des abends
olaf scholz weil wir eine regierung von
grün rot rot oder rot grün eingehen
würde der ist für mich eine absolute
katastrophe und solange er das nicht
ausschließt ist und bleibt er für mich
der versager
wir haben das wort charaktertest gehört
war es für beide
ich glaube an den charakter test dieser
form des interviews klar bestanden wer
meine analyse wenn ich mir jetzt
anschauen wer hatte an dem am heutigen
amt die schwierigere ausgangsposition
mit diesem umfrage schock der heute
morgen da rein gehagelt kam und während
papa stand vielmehr unter druck und
musste viel mehr liefern und irgendwie
überraschend war dass armin laschet aus
meiner sicht und ich glaube das hat er
getan also ich will noch mal eine andere
wollte schlagen die eindeutige verlierer
dieses abends ist annalena baerbock weil
sie ihr gar nicht her kommen wollte der
hat sich wer hier nicht her kommen will
hat sie schon abgemeldet
das ist ein guter punkt
[Musik]